we've covered using cloud monitoring in
your projects but what if you're
responsible for managing many projects
and you need to unify monitoring across
them and how can you control access to
monitoring data for many projects today
we'll look at cloud monitoring metric
scopes and learn how to use them to
monitor multiple cloud projects welcome
to engineering for reliability with
google cloud
let's start with a simple example how
can you make it easier to view
monitoring data from multiple projects
if i go to monitoring settings for my
project i can see that my current metric
scope only has a single project in it
the one i'm currently viewing i can add
others but what's actually happening
here let's have a look at metric scopes
and how they work
when you create a google cloud project
that project hosts a metric scope and
becomes the scoping project for that
scope it stores the alerts uptime checks
dashboards and monitoring groups that
you configure for the scope
for example if you create a staging
project and then access monitoring you
can see the metrics for the resources in
the staging project this happens for
every project you create each project
creates a metric scope for itself and
hosts monitoring configuration for
itself
but what if you want to centralize how
that data is stored and how it's
accessed you can add multiple projects
to an existing scope
now monitoring data for all projects in
that scope will be visible
this will let you do things like create
dashboards showing resources from all
the projects in the scope or alerting
policies that apply to resources in
multiple projects as long as they're in
the metric scope
note that the recommended approach for
production deployments is to create a
dedicated project to host monitoring
configuration data and use its metric
scope to set up monitoring for the
projects that have actual resources in
them this way should a project not be
necessary anymore and get deleted the
monitoring configuration for all the
other projects won't be impacted what
about access
while in this configuration users must
have appropriate iim permissions to
access monitoring data for example a
user would need to have the right role
in the monitoring project to be able to
see monitoring data for both projects
a user who only has access to the
staging project would not be able to see
any monitoring data for the production
project
now that you understand what metric
scopes are and what to use them for
let's have a look at how to set them up
in cloud monitoring
let's start in our staging project
we'll go to compute engine and see that
we have a single vm running
we can go to monitoring and see that
monitoring data for the vm is being
shown
for example on the infrastructure
summary dashboard let's now go to our
monitoring project
and confirm that there aren't any
compute instances running in it
we also don't have the out of the box
compute dashboards because we don't have
any resources running in this project
let's now add our staging project to be
monitored by this metric scope
we can do that in monitoring settings by
adding a project
selecting the project we want to add
and confirming that we want to use this
monitoring project as the scoping
project rather than creating a new scope
once this operation is complete
monitoring data from the staging project
will be visible in this metric scope
we can confirm that by going to the vm
instances dashboard for example
from here we can see more details about
the instance being monitored even though
it's running in another project
so that's how we can use the cloud
console to configure metric scopes and
collect monitoring data from multiple
projects
so that's how to configure metric scopes
in the ui but how can you figure out
where your project is being monitored or
where the monitoring data you can see in
your project is coming from
let's have a look
now that we have added our staging
project to our monitoring metrics scope
let's see how we can navigate between
the two we can see information about our
current metric scope here on the
monitoring overview page for the
monitoring project
if we click on that we can see that the
monitoring project is monitoring metrics
for resources running in the project
itself
and in our staging project we can go
there directly from here
in the staging project we can do the
same thing
and see that this project is monitoring
metrics for itself and that it is being
monitored by our monitoring project and
we can go back to that project simply by
clicking on that link
so that's how you can navigate between
metric scopes and monitored projects in
cloud monitoring
navigating metric scopes on the ui is
easy enough but how can you ensure that
for example new projects are added to
your production monitoring configuration
you can use the api to automate that
let's have a look
let's start in monitoring settings
and confirm that this particular metric
scope is only monitoring this project
which is the scoping project for this
metric scope
now let's go to our api
we'll use the create method for metric
scopes projects which takes two
arguments
first one is the parent which is the
metric scope that we want to add our
staging project to
the second is our project itself which
is a monitored project resource the name
field includes a reference to both the
staging project and the metric scope
we're adding this project to
let's execute this request
authenticate and confirm that the
operation is done
we can now go back to monitoring
settings for our monitoring project
refresh the page
and confirm that the staging project has
been added to this metric scope so
that's how you can use the cloud
monitoring api to manage how projects
are monitored by metric scopes
thanks for joining me today we covered
how metricscopes lets you configure
monitoring across projects and how to
manage them in the ui and using the api
i hope this helps you standardize and
automate your monitoring run more
reliable services and keep your users
happy thanks so much for watching don't
forget to like and subscribe to never
miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon